Superheroes may rely on supervillains for
action and drama, seeing their powers turned
against them or pushed to their limits, but
you don’t need heat vision or super-strength
to be truly terrifying.
Sometimes, all it takes is a criminal blessed
with determination, and an opponent pushing
them to their true potential.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Most Dangerous
Comic Book Criminals.
The Joker
No one knows his story, his motivations, or
his endgame - but everyone knows his name:
Joker.
Over the years, Batman's arch-nemesis has
been portrayed as a serial killer, a crime
boss, a madman, and an agent of chaos, in
nearly every form of entertainment.
Every fan may have their favourite, but The
Joker is so fragmented and crazed, it's impossible
to even call one version more faithful than
any other.
Without any superpower, super weapon, or even
backup, Joker's calculated mayhem hasn't just
made him a comic book icon, but one of the
most complicated and terrifying villains in
history.
Not bad for a guy with nothing but a knife,
a pistol, and a plan.
Kingpin
He may not be much to look at, but Wilson
Fisk has proven to be not only one of the
most brilliant and ruthless crime bosses the
comic book world has ever seen, but a physical
threat capable of fighting some of Marvel’s
most impressive heroes.
Bullied in his childhood because of his weight,
Fisk hit the gym, turning his former bullies
into henchmen, and beginning his rise to the
top of Hell’s Kitchen’s underworld, letting
his fists and wits do the talking, eventually
becoming the Kingpin of Crime.
Don’t be fooled by the lack of a gun or
club, either: The Kingpin prefers to kill
with his bare hands, and whatever furniture
is nearby.
He may not be a supervillain, but a man with
his talents for organized crime who can beat
Daredevil and Spider-Man in a fight deserves
more credit than he’s usually given.
Killer Croc
Born with a rare genetic condition that caused
his skin to grow hard and scaly like a reptile,
Waylon Jones was an outcast, bullied by schoolmates
and abused and abandoned by an alcoholic aunt.
As he grew bigger and badder, a job wrestling
alligators for the circus seemed a waste of
his talents.
Waylon knew how to be tough, and knew a life
of crime was his destiny.
Taking the name Killer Croc, he set out to
organize and rule the criminals of Gotham
City, proving a serious player even without
his bulletproof skin and superstrength.
He would do battle with Batman too many times
to count, but what he lacked in brains, he
made up for in brutality.
Did we mention he's also a cannibal?
The Darkness
As one of the few comic criminals who is neither
good or evil, Jackie Estacado began his life
as an orphan, adopted into the Franchetti
crime family at the tender age of 6.
Making his first kill at the age of 16, Jackie
would become the family’s most skilled and
ruthless hitman, doing more than just killing
his targets to send a message.
But on his 21st birthday, he learned that
his induction into the mafia was no coincidence:
he was the latest in a long line of men entrusted
with The Darkness: an ancient force granting
its host nearly limitless power.
In the hands of Jackie, the power to create
any weapon or creature as long as he stayed
in the shadows was a perfect fit, seeking
vengeance on all who had wronged him in the
past.
With the power to take on Superman himself,
Jackie took over the crime family with ease,
putting his skills learned on the streets
to work taking over an entire country.
The Riddler
Unlike most criminal masterminds, the Prince
of Puzzlers can't resist telling the absolute
truth.
But his need to prove he's the smartest person
in the room means The Riddler can't do anything
simply.
His green costume and obsession with riddles
and brainteasers made Edward Nigma a bit of
a joke to mainstream audiences, but comic
fans have seen him develop into a twisted,
terrifying and truly dangerous criminal over
the years.
The well-known "Hush" storyline saw Riddler
pulling the strings behind every single Batman
villain as part of his plan to bring down
Bruce Wayne once and for all.
More recently, "Batman: Zero Year" saw Riddler
take complete control over Gotham, turning
the city to ruins until a citizen could solve
his riddles.
Puzzles aren't too scary, but in the hands
of The Riddler, they can be fatal.
Carnage
Spider-Man knew that the Alien symbiotic behind
his black suit was bad news, and when it merged
with Eddie Brock to become Venom, his most
popular enemy was born.
But not his most dangerous.
When Brock found himself sharing a cell with
serial killer psychopath Cletus Kasady, he
wanted out - fast.
His alien partner came to the rescue, but
left its child behind, soon entering Kasady's
bloodstream - and just like that, Carnage
was born.
What was most horrifying about the murderous
rampages that followed wasn't the villain's
powers, but placing them in Kasady's hands.
It was the madman's belief that murder was
the mark of true courage that made him a menace,
meaning he's just as deadly without the suit.
He was created to show what DC's Joker could
do if given superpowers, and Carnage has yet
to disappoint.
Bullseye
Putting his skills with throwing projectiles
to use as a baseball player, the pitcher who
would become known as “Bullseye” found
throwing a no-hitter too boring.
Killing the batter with a ball to the head
sent him on his path of murders-for-hire,
becoming one of the deadliest assassins the
Marvel Universe has ever seen.
But becoming a soldier of fortune for villains
like The Kingpin wasn’t enough – Bullseye
wanted fame as well.
Bragging to New York’s Daily Bugle about
his many kills and the fact that he “never
misses” put Daredevil on his tail – and
the two have been at war ever since.
If his mastery of martial arts, guns and blades
wasn’t deadly enough.
Bullseye can turn toothpicks, paperclips,
and even his own teeth into lethal weapons.
For the right price, of course.
Arcade
Who says insanity and homicidal tendencies
can’t be profitable?
The Marvel villain known as “Arcade” learned
there’s good money in killing, and as is
usually the case, bigger is better.
When the pampered young man was cut off by
his wealthy father, he killed him, and took
the money for himself.
Flush with cash and realizing his love of
murder, Arcade became a globetrotting assassin.
But when the murder game became too boring,
he hatched a different plan: he’d build
his own deathtrap known as “Murderworld,”
and drop his targets into the fatal theme
park to give them a fighting chance.
The villain’s similarities to DC’s Joker
are obvious, but his one-of-a-kind humor and
genuine thrill at seeing his victims attempt
to escape made him a hit, appearing alongside
many of Marvel’s most well-known heroes.
Even if that meant he racked up more failures
than kills.
Two-Face
What’s more tragic than seeing an embodiment
of law and order flipped on its head, embracing
crime, chaos and violence instead?
The answer is a man who can’t even decide
between the two.
Every Batman fan knows the tragic story of
Harvey Dent, once an upstanding District Attorney
who develops a split personality when half
of his face is burned with acid.
Although the darker side of his character
may be more than a little crazed, it still
has access to the brilliant intelligence and
knowledge of Gotham’s underworld.
The result is Two-Face, a crime boss who sees
every attack against Gotham as an opportunity.
But what makes the villain truly dangerous
is his signature coin, used to make nearly
every decision facing his fractured mind.
Sure, he may have become predictable over
the years, but when the flip of a coin means
Harvey Dent may help Batman save the day – or
commit an unspeakable act of violence, he
becomes a villain unlike any other the Dark
Knight has had to face.
Prometheus
If there’s one criminal in the world of
DC Comics who is truly underrated, it has
to be Prometheus.
Raised by two criminals, the young boy travelled
across America, learning the outlaw life until
his parents were shot down by police.
Just as Bruce Wayne dedicated his life to
avenging his parents, Prometheus did the same.
Spending time in South American fighting pits,
working as an African mercenary and as an
international terrorist, Prometheus became
a true student of crime and violence, eventually
killing the cops who killed his parents, and
turning his finely-tuned skills to bringing
down the Justice League.
He may have required some gadgets to get the
job done, but an everyday criminal who can
take down Batman, Green Lantern, and Martian
Manhunter deserves some respect.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite comic book
crooks, killer and thieves?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.